consumer matters tonight an example of
how good intentions can go bad in the
transition to electric vehicles a man
who bought a plug-in hybrid was shocked
to find out battery repairs would cost
him more than half what he paid for the
whole car and Dru is here with more and
thanks Chris when Peter buek purchased
his plugin hybrid he says he loved his
car but the relationship with his
vehicle soured after being quoted
thousands of dollars for an electric
battery replacement he said all that
money he saved by avoiding the gas
station have been all for
not Peter bur says when he purchased his
plug-in hybrid electric vehicle he
thought he was being a good Steward of
the environment back in 2017 the Colona
resident purchased a brand new 2018
Hyundai ionic plug-in
hybrid he says he was saving about $300
a month on his gas bill but this past
September the engine light on his hybrid
came on while driving and it would prove
to be a costly fix the Hyundai
dealership told Peter his electric
battery would need to be replaced so I
got a quote the next day for
$5,280 not including labor Peter says he
purchased the vehicle for around
$30,000 what's worse he says the car had
190,000 kmet on it which meant it wasn't
covered under warranty how is it even
statistically possible that one
component of a vehicle can be worth
almost as much as the vehicle Peter says
at the time he received little to no
help from Hyundai Canada to help pay for
the repair I feel like he get kicked in
the teeth he's not alone recently
Global's sha O'Shea interviewed another
Hyundai EV owner in Ontario who was
initially told by a Hyundai dealer it
would cost more than $50,000 to install
a new battery for his 207 ionic all
electric vehicle that also included the
installation and taxes felt like I got
kicked in the privates when it comes to
replacing EV batteries car experts say
consumers should be aware of the costs
from what we've seen on average
reasonable to expect to replace a
battery at a cost anywhere from 15 to
25,000 for most of the more popular
electric vehicles consumer matters
reached out to Hyundai Canada on Peter's
behalf about the cost of his battery and
in a statement we were told Mr bur's
vehicle has surpass a 160,000 kilm
warranty limit by more than 30,000
kilomet which is why the initial
warranty claim was not approved however
our consumer relations team remains
committed to working with him Peter says
he's since been told Hyundai Canada will
cover the cost of the battery and honor
the warranty I can't thank consumer
matters enough for stepping in and
helping me and going to bat for me and
we are glad we could help now Hyundai
Canada also told consumer matters quote
battery Replacements after a warranty
EXP buyers are rare but we recognize
battery costs represent a challenge for
our customers as well as the industry
Hyundai is currently prioritizing the
development of new processes to provide
more coste effective solutions to EV
customers coming out of warranty and if
you have a consumer issue for me you can
email me at consumer matters
globalnews.ca good work thanks very much
an